a legal showdown for Johnny death and
amber her divorce is nasty she's level
charges of abuse against him still amber
arrived late for her first faceoff with
Johnny's lawyer
Johnny's ex Amber Heard alive for her
deposition at 11:30 a.m. an hour and a
half late and the paps well they were
ready to pounce Depp however faces some
serious claims amber says she is the
victim of domestic abuse and Johnny gave
her this black eye in May it's basically
gonna be a he-said she-said his word
against hers Christopher Meltzer is a
family law specialist who has
represented stars like Katie Holmes
during her divorce from Tom Cruise he
doesn't represent either party in this
case but says amber has a tough road
ahead to prove up a permanent
restraining order she has to establish
that Johnny hit her or stalked her
harassed her things like that amber
filed for divorce in May just a month
earlier this was their last appearance
together a PSA I'm truly sorry the
pistol and Boo were not declared Johnny
and amber recorded this awkward apology
apparently part of a settlement for
allegedly smuggling their dogs into
Australia cleared everything when you
enter a strip parties were married for
15 months I would imagine a divorce case
in this situation could take longer than
the marriage itself